[Music]
uh we have a guest a second hour merch
if you introduce it i'll get everything
moving uh we do we uh we're being joined
by a congressional candidate from bucks
county pennsylvania uh caroline avery is
joining us
and uh she is primary against uh what's
what's the guys
look at the guy's name sorry it's fitz
fitzpatrick i know it's a fellow uh you
know potato eater like myself
um it's more of like a i guess a neocon
uh it this is another one of those kind
of uprising races right yeah
so welcome oh yeah so welcome to the
show oh yeah
so tell us what's going on hi uh royce
and um
mike whatever mike you call whatever you
want it's fine we don't like them anyway
um
[Laughter]
so um
yeah so uh so so what's going on i i i
was
you switched parties to run is that what
i heard
yeah yes actually my name is caroline
avery and i'm running for the first
congressional district pa
pa01 that's a us house seat my opponent
is fbi agent slash congressman
brian fitzpatrick we call him lovingly
bryno
i love it
right rhino
um
i was always an independent voter and
then in 2015 2016
we both my husband myself felt the um
country was going really in the wrong
direction we registered as republicans
so that we could vote in the primary for
donald trump
so that really was my extent of my inner
tanglings with the republicans
fast forward to about 2019
a lot of people were showing their
dislike for brian fitzpatrick and for
good reason
and they came to me and asked me if i
would run and because i was registered
as a republican
i entered into that race and within day
one
was uh immediate pushback immediate
problems
from day one
now what what what do you think
sorry what do you think that is uh why
do you think that you you started
getting uh you got pushed back
immediately because immediately they
came to me with a i don't know who they
thought they were dealing with some
whole other person but immediately they
came to me with things like you know
maybe you should run in this race
instead
i'm not an ass looking for a seat i was
looking to unseat period
um they started with uh come to these
dinners and just all kind of baloney i
come from professional horse racing i
know what [ __ ] looks like and it was
[ __ ] and it didn't get better at all
it only got worse and the more that i
would not allow them to
um
corrupt me the worse it got but you know
i just kept going anyway i it was what
it was i didn't let it bother me too
much
now
was um they tried to stop me at every
turn they you know
harassed me all that other stuff i got
my signatures um against all odds uh
they you know trashed me on facebook i'm
talking about the rhinos not republicans
i met a bunch of great republican
conservatives that i'm to this day
really good friends with
but um so they harassed me even some
famous people harassed me and i've got
the proof of that too and i was getting
ready to withdraw from the race because
i just didn't want to deal with any of
these people anymore i just didn't want
to deal with them they're no good and
then they slapped me with the elias
group
uh a challenge to my signatures
and on its face i could see that um
it was malicious because i knew that
many of these signatures were a bunch of
my friends i knew for a fact these were
good signatures so that just kind of
pissed me off
so instead of withdrawing i went down
the supreme court and i proved
to my satisfaction
that they were malicious and then i
withdrew my petition and withdrew my
candidacy and within 48 hours i joined
the libertarian party because they had
already reached out to me via second
amendment of um organizations and stuff
like that because i'm a good candidate
and so that that's my story for the for
that
so this guy is like he's an fbi agent
he's not even from bucks county right
he's from philly
so he's one of these guys that just like
you know is now did you did
i heard something of the effect of this
guy who like supports the uh assault
weapons bill or i hate even saying the
word assault weapon but uh basically he
supports stricter gun control right
that's putting it mildly and i think
that's awful rich of a man who's an fbi
agent who's going to be able to carry a
firearm arm for his entire life because
he's an fbi agent so he doesn't really
care rules for thee but not for me
um and you know this is here to say but
i'm saying anyway because i talked to a
lot of people i probably talked about 15
000 individuals one of his friends told
me that in a private conversation which
i'm just saying this is just hearsay
that he told a friend of his that he
thought no one should have guns except
for police and the military
and i said would you go on the record
with that and of course they said no
because everybody's afraid of him so
being afraid of your congressmen
is not a good thing and that is
if that's the only thing to run on you
should run on that because being afraid
of your government is not okay
so um they look and by the way i i
believe that i i think a lot a lot of
rhinos and there's there's a lot of as i
like to call them dan crenshaw types who
say a lot of stuff
uh but when it comes but when it comes
to it but when it comes down to it you
know they don't care if you have guns
they really do believe that the military
and the police should be the only ones
uh that have it and you know you're not
the first candidate that we've heard
that from we we interviewed anthony
sabatini who had the same issue where
he's like a bunch of rhinos like kevin
mccarthy's throwing money to my
opponents and i'm like
what what do you do you at that point
you have the entire
neocon infrastructure basically
funding your opponent it's really
difficult no matter how good of a
candidate you are
to push through it
well
it gets worse because
we have people who work for the gop as
like treasurers and things like that
those are my objectives and they are
using the elias firm as their lawyers
first of all where are these people who
are committing people and just treasures
for like the local gop where are they
getting the money for these huge law
firms like follow their money okay just
anything if this is like round three for
me to stop me from competing and it's
not just um the the one
the one offense with brian i mean let's
just get it here let's just we're not
being represented not even remotely
right this three-term congressman agent
brian fitzpatrick his voting record he
censured trump he voted to
marjorie taylor green of her committee
seats
and i understand the debt depth of that
that means that her constituents don't
get their voice represented properly in
washington dc and that's absolutely
unacceptable
uh he let's see what else did he do he
voted for the 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill um he most recently
voted for the 180 hr 1808 which is the
the gun ban the uh semi-automatic gun
ban there's our friend briana right
there um he he's uh in 20 well not in
2018 but uh in 2018 debate
he uh
he brought up the fact that he at one
point was stationed in
ukraine
uh-huh yeah yes
so here we go so he's also also gay he's
also behind the 40 billion to ukraine
speaking of ukraine let's see did brian
murphy james comey in 2015
as the special prosecutor
under the obama biden administration
during all the barismo debacle
okay
and couldn't find anybody to prosecute
so your leader
wow i mean i mean rhino this is just
basically he's one of the nine
republicans that voted to hold uh bannon
and contempt too are you serious oh my
this is this is like this is a classic
like january 6th guy that's like
so you guys i didn't know you guys i
didn't know you guys had like your own
little like liz cheney up there in
pennsylvania yeah that's basically what
he is yourself your own little except
fbi liz cheney
yeah yeah he's he's
very it's it's very nefarious and it
takes brass
balls to go against the sky you know i
have i'm in no way a male but i have a
spine and a backbone and i'm really i've
had it i am done i am done with this
crap doing this to our country and and
doing this to the american people do you
know how many people my community are
afraid of their congressmen this is
unacceptable i won't have it i'm done
with it
wow you're done with it this guy
has stayed completely silent on the
january sixers okay with the their loss
of their fourth amendment right we have
due process in this country
i don't care what you did i don't care
if you killed your sister you need to be
held
accountable for crimes and things like
that but we have a thing called due
process in this country he stayed
completely quiet about this
a friend of mine even said they had him
come speak at a um you know an event for
them and when they brought it up
he acted like he didn't even know what
it was he said huh
so he let those people and a lot of
those people are from the area he let
those people
sit there and rot and and br in jail
a congressman a sitting congressman you
know i'm really glad you're saying
something about that because i think
that's something that that'll that this
has happened that's happening a lot is
specifically with the january 6 stuff
like it really has shown the true colors
of who people are do like there's a lot
of republicans that need to be taking
the task for not saying something that
just not only saying something agreeing
like you know lindsey graham you know
you have guns use them it's it's
that level of they disdain
for you and this guy man i'm i'm funny
because i want to thank you virtue by to
open secrets and third third third
highest contributor royal bank of canada
uh yeah then uh no labels which is like
some weird coalition uh
and uh
yeah and man it's always the money you
know when you look at the atlas holdings
republican jewish coalition
i mean big cat rescue
carol basketball hold on a second oh my
god are you telling me that crazy woman
carol oh my god
the one who may or may not have fed her
husband to tigers yeah sorry go ahead
not endorsed by gabby giffords gun
grabbers okay which should have gone to
his democrat opponent right okay so he's
basically a one-horse race because he
doesn't win anything he stops other
people from competing
okay yeah this guy is a bad guy
no business he has no business
having a seat like this whatsoever
public and also i want to say that his
signs and his motto say one community
i think he spelled communists wrong yeah
well
i mean it's you know it's funny because
i'm looking as through people that
donate and i'm trying to big cat red we
live in florida so i'm brick hat rescues
that'll carol baskin tiger king thing
but she lives here why would big cat
rescue which is a florida cat rescue
thing donate so much money to a
pennsylvania race i'm sorry these things
are weird there's a lot of weird stuff
here like you know obviously you know
more about him than we do but even just
like the eyeball like us first looking
at it this guy is shady in like 50
different ways you know what i mean
well the thing is yes i do and the thing
is is i really want to bring this to
your attention and i hope a lot of
people see this sure because
when loser draw
this ain't over this ain't over by a
long shot because i'm committed this is
this is not going to end until it's
going to end because this guy is doing
the wrong thing on a regular basis and
he's getting away with it he's not being
held accountable whatsoever he's not
doing anything about the child
trafficking he's he's putting ukraine
before before our pennsylvania
um
you know
it just goes on and on and on and he
cares nothing he it doesn't faze him
whatsoever we can never forget that this
guy is an fbi agent yeah i mean that to
me by the way that that to me is always
and especially there's a lot of them
running now it's odd that's what it
means a lot of these like
ex-intelligence people and it's like
it's like that it is very weird to me
because it is a lot of that it's it's
right off the bat when it's an ex
fbi agent i'm like okay something shady
there's something weird i don't and i
know it sucks to think that way but you
have to now because i mean man they're
raiding people that did nothing they're
raiding people they're taking the pillow
guy's phone away yeah they're taking
them back they're literally subpoenaing
the my fellow guy taking his phone man
this is getting like dystopian
i have people
who
sign my petition that are total
strangers to me they just sign my
petition right to get me on the ballot
i've done legally ethically and morally
i've done everything i'm supposed to do
to get on the ballot and compete
okay
and he
somebody from his office contacted them
and told them that somebody was going to
jail they tried to intimidate her they
showed her a screenshot of my petitions
they work at bryant for brian or they
were working on his behalf because she
wrote me a letter she wrote me an
affidavit and told them that i was a
democrat
and that i was unseating a republican
and that i was a liar first of all
those things are not true second of all
she fought back she said how dare she
said those are my signatures that is my
signature my husband's signature and how
dare you call me and threatening with
jail they went to one of my circulators
and team members house and and and
threatened them
okay
we're putting the pieces together and
threatened him in front of his wife and
family
and children
this is because
it's honestly a couple of years ago i
probably would have been like you sound
crazy but now crazy person but like this
is becoming more like the with the stuff
we know
the stuff we know happening with other
people too well but i mean if the guy's
an fbi agent you know he has friends and
you know he has resources and i'm sorry
to say but that's the truth
and and and if it's it's of course
getting intimidated it happens all the
time they intimidate you it's what it is
and and and it's amazing the only thing
that i am glad about is that i think the
the one thing that that it's coming to
light has been how many
rhinos there really are and when you
really start looking into them you start
looking into like oh you work for obama
oh you work for the oh wait that's weird
to your republic i mean
my my thing is i
that this the republican party needs to
be just cleaned out from top to bottom
from a lot of these old old money
neocons and the mitch mcconnell's and
this guy what you know i got to tell you
like merch just said if you would have
said that like 10 years ago like okay
yeah right but now you're like you know
they're doing it right now and you know
what you know the crazy part of caroline
is they're not even
back they back in the day they used to
hide it they're not they're telling you
they're doing it and they're proud of it
they're saying it's for democracy that
you know this guy needs to be there and
they'll slander you and they'll say the
worst things about you and they'll
intimidate you
okay so you got rhyme rhinos and
progressives yeah those to me are code
words for commies okay
let's hear what the i'm a gun owner of
america endorse candidate mm-hmm okay
right
yeah gun owners of america saw fit to
endorse me
a libertarian okay
over this should have been easily
secured by a good republican correct of
course um let's
hear what the gun owners of america has
to say about brian
they say
i am proud to endorse caroline avery for
congress in the first in the
pennsylvania's first congressional
district anti-gun congressman
fitzpatrick continues to violate the
constitutionally protected rights of gun
owners he was one of the two republicans
voted for the 1808 which so-called
assault ban
that would outlaw just about every
semi-automatic firearm in circulation
but brian's offenses don't stop here
here are some more he's sponsored the
closing the bump stock loophole act
close sponsored the bipartisan
bipartisan uh background checks enhanced
background checks and it just goes on
and on and on with this guy it's never
ending he's
totally
unremorseful
that
he's
um
it's just a matter of fact like you know
he's just taking it for granted and i'm
really i'm really starting to bother
these people and you know for good
reason for good reason they need to be
bothered they need to be bothered this
needs to come out this needs to come out
in light to what they're doing with all
of this and we have made we have kept
good records there are many people that
are very um
they have much good integrity they can
be relied upon for testimony
um and
uh we're just gonna i'm gonna keep going
on this is this has to this has to stop
what what so so democrats
so real quick caroline just because i
want to make sure we get this out there
for you specifically what can people do
like what can people that are in in you
know your area what what can they do
to to help to you know to help you out
definitely need that right go to
caroline for congress spell.or
dot us okay i don't know if you can put
that up on your yeah i'll put it up
i'd be grateful if you
um you know we're you know we're real
true grassroots um i'm all over the
place so anybody that wants to help is
welcome to help uh mostly donate and
word of mouth word of mouth he wants to
make sure that other people don't know
that anybody else is in the race
uh i just was invited to an oz event
writing on my own backyard which is his
backyard
and the first flyer said that he was
going to be a speaker there so i
definitely wanted to show up
and um i went to the event
and brian was a no-show
how do you feel about it doesn't show up
at the event
go ahead marcia i was gonna say how do
you feel about uh dr oz or whatever
well i feel that i have to worry about
my race and let dr oz worry about his
race right now that's how i feel about
it that's right that's you know what
honestly that's that's absolutely that's
that's a fair answer um and you know
remember like we're from florida so we
don't really know to we don't get to you
know we see we only we only know about
you know your race is what you see on
the national news and stuff like that
but i'll be honest with you
um i was a little taken aback by even
just like mercer was doing and i do just
just just a cursory google on this on
this brian fitzpatrick guy red there's a
lot of red flags you're like oh this guy
yeah ukraine fbi ukraine money and
that's a lot of weird yeah and stuff
like that so so i guess that the next
question that i i this is because it's
topical and i'm sure a lot of people
want to know this what do you think
about um what's happening in martha's
vineyard and the and the uh and uh the
illegal immigrants being bust there
i think it's brilliant
i think that i think it should have been
done a long time ago because it really
doesn't suffer anybody but you know
hard-working folks with like myself that
live on the outskirts of a big city when
you you know do this
um and you know i don't both i don't
bash anybody from wanting to come to
america i can understand that but i
think they exactly need to be put right
there in those people's backyard and let
them
let them suffer the consequences
you know this this whole monarchy thing
i really need to get back to this brian
is an fbi agent so many people are so
angered and he's canceled them all him
and his few group of people have
cancelled them all many of these
veterans and gun owners and gun um you
know uh target places and stuff like
that they feel absolutely
um
humiliated because they've been tricked
by him and so when i go went to speak to
them i said
forgive yourself because this is a
trained agent he's they call them
special agents for a reason
they're specially trained to lie and to
deceive and to go about going unnoticed
so it doesn't really matter that i'm up
here and you don't know about him if he
was in florida there's a good reason
good
there's a reasonable
understanding that you might not hear
about him there either right right but i
mean it's it's it's the whole
you know
to just keep all the connections low-key
hey i'm a guy just like you look at me i
believe in these values but at the end
of the day they never really
they never really i mean just just look
at what's going on they never really
they never really have your goals yeah
they do it they're honestly that's what
i believe it's like ex-fbi agent i'm a
big believer of like i don't really
think you ever are really an ex-fbi
agent though you know i mean a lot of
the if they call you go hey man i need
you to help me out
how much control
that's my issue with with any of the
three letter agencies by the way i mean
first off i don't think the atf should
exist so let's start there but followed
by the irs promptly after and the epa
and the epa
um but any anytime you see somebody that
that has a higher gear like that where
they are controlled you're like well
what do these puppet strings look like
you know i mean at the end of the day if
they go look hey we're gonna we're gonna
raid people and we need you to be all
for it you know hey we're gonna rape
people in bucks county hey we're doing
it now and then he'll be like yeah i
know i agree these are criminals if they
tell them to do it i don't you
i don't really think that you ever stop
being a a cia agent or an fbi age you
might not do the work every day but if
they call you to do a favor most of
these guys they're going to do it
you don't listen he also signed in that
equality act that lets men participate
in women's sports and this guy is an
absolute how is this guy a republican
yeah how how is he i mean i know what
you're saying exactly but he wait he
signed the the
let trans people compete with women
think too
yeah i mean it just goes on and on and
on and on with this guy
on and on and on there's not enough and
look at and he depends on that too i
mean i i think it was a may of
or 2019 was it
yeah man 29 2020. he wasn't sure if he
was going to vote for joe biden or
donald trump i mean
say what you want about donald trump and
his personality right but if you're a
republican congressman
and in may
before the november presidential
election you haven't decided he's not on
he's not on anybody's team and you know
i don't think he's the he i don't think
he's the top of the food chain by a long
shot but i've got a lot of light on me
right now so and i speak out so
not overly concerned about it but um
you know there's a certain amount of
concern about it oh okay
i just pulled up this is amazing i mean
you really have open writes a lot i just
went to his i went to his campaign page
every one of these quality and diversity
and he's walking around with a pride
flag his entire website i'm looking at
all of his like positions here yeah yeah
they're literally all democratic
positions every single one
this is
on both times of my cases trying to boot
me off the ballot
the elias group do you know who that is
do you know who mark elias is no please
and google him yeah go ahead please
don't let us know i actually would like
to know
on on the elias group's homepage he
helped pay for the steel door cea i
think yeah um
on his home page it says
we are committed okay so he uses the
word committed we are committed to
getting democrats elected and helping
progressives get elected so why are gop
republican objectors
against me
using that law firm
to hurt me because it's a uniparty we
don't have choices we do not have
choices those people the
the rhinos and the progressives pick the
candidates that we get to choose from
and that's it that's not choice that is
not choice
oh my god
i'm just going through it through his
through his uh
his stances the quintessence the
quintessential adjective used around the
word to describe that it to me that
america's a word of free freedom means
freedom for everybody lgbtq americans
are part of the fabric of society and
should be free to exercise the right
guaranteed every american by which the
constitution to participate fully in
society okay okay so what what is it at
this point that lgbt people aren't
is there something happening we don't
know about they're not getting house
loans are they like getting shut out of
jobs
in congress
they're harming gay people okay they're
using gay people i grew up i'm i'm from
i'm a surfer girl from the 60s okay 60s
and 70s and you don't get more hippie
type than me i lived in miami during
when all that stuff was going down with
the uh you know the a wax with reagan
and all that stuff and you know
listen
gay people in general they don't have
all these issues and and any of that
this is this is their private business
right but what they're doing is they're
they're separating everybody by you know
these pronouns and and you know whether
you're republican democrat
uh gabe lesbian this that trans they're
confusing our children the children the
children are terrified to look in their
underpants and some of the adults
you're right no it's it's true i mean
that's that's 100 true now and and
and then you know what
he's healthy
oh yeah oh no i mean i i i mean i i i
believe it it it's it's um
what was how was how was he with covet
you know that's something i guess you
would you would know better than us how
was he with uh with the whole clover
thing
he was with he was with richard levine
who's now the health secretary for joe
biden richard levine aka rachel levine
admiral
oh [ __ ] oh yeah
right
with me you've been with me for all this
time i mean this guy is really i mean he
makes liz cheney look like i don't know
maybe dorothy from the wizard of oz
he's got that father you know i mean so
dude that's wild yeah that's a big
bucks county's got a hell of a [ __ ]
weird rabbit hole to go down yeah you
you guys wow this is insane i'm looking
at this now like
yeah this guy i mean
millions
well we have about in my district okay
because there's a little bit of
montgomery county all about county and
there's give or take about
675 000 people
and
we're hurting
we need help and we're not getting it
from these people that's for dancer
people are pulling for me
the people they're angry he's actually
by trying to stop me from competing on
the ballot he's actually going to make
it worse on himself why can't he just
feed me on the merits i'm a housewife
that lives on morris street why can't
this fbi agent three-term congressman uh
lawyer uh his brother was a congressman
uh he's a prosecutor for
ukraine under comey why can't he just
beat me
why does he have to stop me via i call
it lawfare
right
right well that's true i mean if if if
they if they threaten to to arrest
everybody or even worse tie you up in
frivolous legal battles that you know
listen let's be honest that's a great
way to shut people down and people can't
afford to fight legally what do you do
you know
what are you doing it it really it
really is amazing go ahead
i'm so sorry i get very passionate no
you're going to be your own lawyer i was
my only first case against elias group
and i spun those boys around like a top
and they didn't like it a little bit and
they've come back for seconds and they
are not playing and you know it's
playing an attorney this time thank
goodness but they are not playing i mean
i am not their friend
i mean they were
humiliated and
yes
wow i mean this this is this is honestly
i gotta tell you
very very eye-opening because everybody
talks about the big stuff but i mean
there's so much
there's so much corruption going on
locally and i think those i think these
local elections and these congressional
elections like matter so much more
because that's like your city your
county this is where you live this is
where you are
and and and that those are the little
things we figured out during covid you
don't really realize how much power
local government has over you until they
they enact these emergency powers that
you didn't know that they had and then
they go look hey every every single food
place is closed now you don't get to go
outside we're flattening the curve we're
flattening the curve that's what's
happening we're all flat in the curve
and everyone get 53 vaccines i guess or
whatever um it is really nice that the
libertarian party um at least gave you a
home
um
are you going to be on the ballot
well we're in the supreme court now okay
they tied my case with another case who
was an absolute loser even my lawyer
they tried to get that lawyer to cover
them and my lawyer said no that's a
loser caroline's a winner this case is a
loser when we get to court this other
person that is a loser comes straggling
along and and on my tail and clears the
whole case i mean it's absolutely
bizarro but we appealed it
and i have to you know i have to have
faith to a degree
okay i have faith i have to have faith
i have to pray and have faith the good
people of this district want to see me
on the ballot over 6 000 people signed
my petition
to get me on the ballot i was only
required to get a little over 2300 and
change
okay
so
counting with the ones i got before over
6 000 people in this district if and
that's only because i got two feet if i
had four feet i would have been able to
get twelve thousand they won't he
he's stopping
the american people in his own district
from
being able to have a choice to say
to vote for anybody else except for him
it really it's not if this is not
a local race this is a big deal this is
this is a u.s house state yes
uh federal
okay i could make a difference i am
ready to be congressman on congresswoman
on day one i have already done more for
election integrity than brian
fitzpatrick will ever do
because they can't print the ballots and
put them in a little mailbox real fast
until my case gets cleared up because
they want to print them last week and
start mailing them in so i've already
done more than he's ever done
are you getting any uh help from the
libertarian party are you getting a
little support from those guys
extremely
um
kind to me it's been the exact opposite
of what i uh it's what i saw in the like
rhino gop let me make it very clear i
met a ton of conservative people that
love me and are still behind me and
they'll vote for me in fact they even
want to write me in
okay if it comes to it it's that bad
it's that bad people are so irate over
it and to stop me from to stop me from
competing is completely it's un-american
and um
so the libertarian party you know
they're just like wow because i'm a
fireball they're like oh my god this is
was totally a winnable race for me this
could be a winnable race and this is why
they're trying to stop me but if he's so
great then he shouldn't he should
welcome competition but especially from
a woman woman but he doesn't care about
that
yeah i guess i get i get that either and
it's funny you say that carol likes i
was actually when you look at his
website one of the tabs is women
empowerment and he's he's taking you
through the ringer and using the
government to try to stop you he's
really empowering you it really is it
really goes to show you that just
you send jack booted thugs to intimidate
women you're treating them just as equal
as the men that you're enemies with i
say that's empowering i mean it's really
insane to me and i got to tell you
caroline i i i mean i don't want to
speak for mercy but i'm actually really
impressed because considering all all
this adversity that you're going through
and actually seeing what this dude's
about on our own just looking it up it
really is impressive how hard you're
fighting back and i'm glad that they
can't even send them out yet i'm glad
you that you just threw that wrench in
there and be like no let's solve this
now right
i have got true grit and i've had enough
i have had enough i am going all the way
through
no matter if she's if the supreme court
says yay the supreme court says nay it's
it's going to be the same for me i'm
going through this guy this is enough
for our country and the thing about it
is is like when you get someone like me
that is willing to go like this all the
way
through yes
get home
they get hope and they start
they start coming around it's like it's
like i'm the mellow yellow car you know
that the movie um with the tom tom
cruise with the race car drivers
dates of thunder
days of thunder i love that movie
the car and the mellow yellow car are
really owned by the same sponsor so
let's call the sponsor the american
people yeah okay but the coke car break
the the mello the coke car crashes which
is brian fitzpatrick one big crash okay
and then the mellow yellow car gets into
the pits and there's got nobody to
really help him and all of a sudden they
go get over there or change the tires do
all that in the middle yellow car wins
and i can totally be the mellow yellow
car
well look i i need help i i and again
you know we've been posting your link
i'm gonna clip this interview and put it
up of course
um where where where people can uh can
go and and donate we're coming up here
you know towards the end but um is there
anything else immersed at you no i'm
willing to uh support her over my own
over my own people yeah my own my own
potato people there you go and that's
saying a lot can you turn my back on on
a fitzpatrick
you know what
this guy's earned it a fed's a fed a
fed's a fed
the good news is if i get on the ballot
and i tell them to this if what's the
big deal put me on the ballot god knows
you have plenty of things to try to
discredit me with let them do that why
can't you try to discredit me you know
what i mean well i'm probably afraid
you're going to split the vote
you know they're probably afraid you're
going to split the vote and then you
know the democrat will sneak in
listen it's sneak in so they're going to
fix it for us so that we don't get what
they don't what they don't want
no free and fair elections this is the
deal you get
you get the government you deserve and
we all get it
not just the people who deserve it
and you know caroline i i better get it
i tell you what i wish i was there
because i i you would have my vote for
sure um we really do appreciate uh you
you coming on and and
you know what i tell you what the the
the next time you come the next time
you're welcome on whenever you'd like
but hopefully one day we we we're seeing
a congressman
caroline avery when you come in so i i i
really do hope so
um yes thank you so much for having me
on your show um i'm very passionate i
hope i didn't take up too much of your
time not at all
i try to stay on point
i'm going to close our borders open up
our economy
men aren't women state the government
get out of your bedroom
let's get it together people for the
kids kids kids yes thank you so much
carolyn
wonderful thank you caroline so much i
hope you have a wonderful day yeah and
good luck uh caroline for congress dot
us that's right take it easy bye
man that honestly bro
when we did this interview i was like
okay it's gonna be a normal interview
but it's like the rabbit hole the rabbit
hole that i was the both of us were
going through with this pennsylvania's
[ __ ] up bro
dude this guy was doing everything you
could look it up this guy was doing
everything she was saying and i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on in the state
definitely getting that regional pa
thing that was getting that jrc35 yeah
yeah okay yeah okay pokey news that's
got to be a regional thing right it is
it is she's she was great i really
enjoyed her